[Musik]
sechs jahre und einen tag nach dem
deutschen überfall auf polen
unterzeichnet japan am 2 september 1945
die kapitulationsurkunde
der zweite weltkrieg ist beendet
wie viele menschen in diesem krieg
gestorben sind wird niemand je genau
wissen ebenso wenig den namen des ersten
oder den des letzten opfers
[Musik]
doch es sind menschen die in diesem
krieg gelitten und gekämpft haben
ohne sie wären panzer nicht gewollt
flugzeuge nicht geflogen und schiffe
nicht gefahren
[Musik]
im krieg geht es um menschen mit oder
ohne uniform
menschen in städten dörfern wäldern
verbündete fremde
verfeindeten nachbarn
[Musik]
hunderte millionen menschen die sechs
jahre und einen tag lang die hölle auf
erde durchlebten
[Musik]
die japaner sonnen sich in ihren frühen
erfolgen sind regelrecht siegestrunken
admiral tomoaki erklärt am neujahrstag
hauptsache ist dass wir gewinnen und das
werden wir sicher
am zwölften mai nur etwas mehr als vier
monate später nach der schlacht im
korallen mehr schlägt der admiral in
seinem tagebuch andere töne an
der traum vom großen erfolg ist geplatzt
[Musik]
der angriff auf pearl harbor am siebten
dezember 1941 ist zwar ein schock und
auch eigentlich keine überraschung
in china waren viele froh darüber denn
für sie ist der krieg noch längst nicht
vorbei
ingbert iks viele erfahrungen die der
westen mit dem krieg verbindet selbst so
symbolträchtige wie der blitz in london
haben die chinesen auch gemacht
sogar vor dem westen offen jennys mutter
fest
[Musik]
auch der britische premierminister
winston churchill nimmt die nachrichten
aus pearl harbor mit erleichterung auf
er sagte später er sei an dem abend ins
bett gegangen und habe den schlaf der
gerechten und geretteten geschlafen
er wusste dass amerikas eintritt in den
krieg das gleichgewicht zu ungunsten
nazideutschlands verschieben würde
[Applaus]
vier tage nach pearl harbor verkündet
hitler im reichstag deutschland habe den
usa den krieg erklärt
joachim von ribbentrop hitlers
außenminister fragt wann ist eine
vermutete nation dieser art je zu einer
rasse von kämpfern und fliege assen
geworden hitler erklärt den amerikanern
traue ich eine ganz große zukunft
deshalb nicht zu weil sie in meinen
augen ein verdeckter und korrupter staat
sind
dazu kommen noch gesellschaft gegensätze
in der schwersten form
[Applaus]
in seiner rede zur lage der nation
wendet sich der us-präsident am 6 januar
an die amerikaner und an die ganze welt
bremen ddp
[Musik]
features so hitler glaubte dass die
amerikaner wenn sie in den krieg
eintreten sollten so sehr mit dem
pazifik raum beschäftigt wären das für
europa nur wenig zeit und ressourcen
übrig bleiben würden es kam genau
andersrum roosevelt setzte den
schwerpunkt zuerst auf europa
bemerkenswerterweise
in seiner ansprache teilt roosevelt der
welt mit dass die vereinigten staaten
60.000 und 1943
125.000 flugzeuge bauen würden
45.000 panzer im jahr 1942 und weitere
75.000 im jahr 1943
[Musik]
roosevelt war schon charismatisch
er erreichte die menschen was ihn von
leuten wie hitler oder mussolini
unterschied war sein glaube an die
demokratischen institutionen wie er
respektierte immer die grenzen der
amerikanischen verfassung
große welt ist fest entschlossen die
angekündigten produktionszahlen zu
erreichen oder sogar zu übertreffen
er holt sich einen geschäftsmann ins
team donald schmerzen vizepräsident der
sears roebuck große welt richtet eine
neue behörde ein das war production bord
er fragte herzen ob er mit dem namen
einverstanden sei nelson findet ihn in
ordnung
große wird erwidert
ich bin froh dass sie einverstanden sind
denn sie sind der vorsitzende des web
protection bord
[Musik]
donald merzen bringt die ohnehin starke
industrie noch mehr in schwung die in
der tat in der zeit in der die japaner
einen flugzeugträger bauten bauten die
amerikaner 24 damit konnten die japaner
nicht mithalten in der modernen
kriegsführung geht es vor allem um
produktionskapazitäten und logistik ist
darin waren die amerikaner den japanern
haushoch überlegen
[Musik]
die amerikanische kriegswirtschaft
leistet erstaunliches
1941 produzieren die amerikanischen
werften schiffe mit einem gesamtgewicht
von 794 1000 tonnen in den folgenden
drei jahren sind es 21 millionen tonnen
[Musik]
1940 produzieren die vereinigten staaten
2141 flugzeuge
1944 sind es 96
bis 1943 produzieren 18 amerikanische
werften zusammen drei
14.000 tonnen fracht schiffe pro tag
das bekommen die anwohner der werften
aus nächster nähe mit
[Applaus]
die arbeit an den schiffen stand nie
still ob früh oder spät man konnte das
dröhnen der bauarbeiten noch fünf meilen
von der werft entfernt hören
es heißt dass die amerikanische
industrie alle fünf minuten einen panzer
alle halbe stunde ein flugzeug und jede
zweite woche einen flugzeugträger
produziert
[Applaus]
die direkte bedrohung kommt für die usa
nicht vom pazifik sondern über den
atlantik
von januar bis juli 1942 versenkten
deutsche u boote vor der amerikanischen
ostküste und in der karibik
397 schiffe
[Musik]
die deutschen nennen es das unternehmen
paukenschlag
spitzname zweite glückliche zeit
[Applaus]
die erste glückliche zeit hatte etwa ein
jahr zuvor die längste schlacht des
krieges eingeleitet die atlantic
schlacht
damals im märz 1941 hatte der erste lord
der admiralität gesagt wir müssen sowohl
den unternehmen als auch den arbeitern
klarmachen dass wir im hinblick auf die
bevorstehende atlantik schlacht jedes
bisschen energie brauchen und eine
stetig steigende produktion
[Applaus]
[Musik]
großbritanniens insellage mag das land
vor einer invasion bewahrt haben aber
sie hat auch ihre nachteile
die britische marine ist zwar stark und
die handelsflotte gigantisch knapp ein
drittel der welthandels turnage ist
kritisch
aber 42 prozent der eingeführten
produkte stammen aus den kolonien des
empire und großbritannien ist auf diese
produkte angewiesen sie sind kein luxus
sondern überlebenswichtig
[Musik]
winston churchill sagte später
das einzige wovor ich während des
krieges wirklich angst hatte waren die u
boote eine invasion so dachte ich schon
vor der luftschlacht würde scheitern
aber die u-boote gefährdeten unsere
versorgung besonders die handelswege und
vor allem die zugänge zu unserer insel
[Musik]
admiral karl dönitz befehle ich die u
boote aber nicht in der anzahl der für
notwendig hält
es dauert bis 1942 er hitler einräumt
unsere u boot waffe ist eine der
kriegsentscheidenden waffen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nachdem die deutschen frankreich besetzt
haben rückt die deutsche u boot flotte
über die französischen häfen näher an
die atlantischen schifffahrtswege heran
von juli bis oktober 1940 werden 282
alliierte schiffe versenkt das
entspricht einem verlust von 1.000.000
1795 tonnen an schiffen und ladung
wird ein schiff getroffen ist das für
viele der menschen an bord ein
todesurteil und für die überlebenden
eine traumatische erfahrung
der wind heulte in der takelage
ich konnte sehen wie einst der großen
handelsschiffe in den gewaltigen wellen
auf die seite gekippt war
[Applaus]
das rettungsboot wurde irgendwie
runtergelassen und wir kletterten hinein
leinen los brüllt jemand als das boot
voll war aber sofort kamen schade und
gebrüll von oben als antwort nein nein
wartet eine sekunde
[Musik]
wir stehen zutiefst in der schuld der
handelsmarine die große mehrheit der
menschen in unserem land weiß was sie
dem sie läuten schuldet
rund 100.000 menschen werden bis mai
1945 im zuge der atlantik schlacht
getötet die opfer sind zu fast gleichen
teilen matrosen der alliierten der
deutschen kriegsmarine und
besatzungsmitglieder und passagiere der
handelsmarine
[Musik]
taktik und waffen entwickeln sich im
lauf der schlacht immer weiter
die wichtigste neuerung für die
alliierten sind die geleit züge aber die
haben auch ihre nachteile
geleit züge hätten die effizienz der
schifffahrt musste man warten bis
genügend schiffe zusammen waren
behindern bestimmte auf dem weg von a
nach b immer der langsamste das tempo
aber
immerhin zwangen die fahrt im verbund
die deutschen u-boote sich den abwehr
schiffen zu stellen wenn sie ihre ziele
angreifen wollten
die deutschen taten alles um den
kontroll zu zerstören aber die winkel
scheiterte wie im letzten krieg haben
bleibt sogar diesmal ihre wirksamkeit
bewiesen
die taktik wird verbessert aber der
strapaziöse alltag an bord über oder
unter wasser ändert sich dadurch nicht
alle sind in ständiger anspannung die
sich durch das leben in einer stahlröhre
ergibt
der banker raum die monotonie die
schlechte luft
bis relativ spät im krieg können die
damaligen u boote nicht lange unter
wasser bleiben
sie müssen oft für längere zeit
auftauchen
währenddessen sind sie natürlich
sichtbar
und verwundbar
die deutsche kriegsmarine verliert
zwischen 1939 und
784 ihrer 863 eingesetzten u boote und
30.000 von 40.000 mann besatzung
[Applaus]
im verhältnis sind die verluste höher
als in jeder anderen militär gattung bei
jeder beteiligten kriegspartei
laut admiral dönitz kommen 1942 auf
jedes verlorene deutsche u-boot 100.000
bruttoregistertonnen versenkte
alliierter schiffsraum
mai 1943 schrumpft dieser wert auf
10.000 tonnen
ende mai musste zugeben dass die
atlantic schlacht fürs erste verloren
ist
den u boot krieg führte aber weiter
trotz unverhältnismäßig hoher verluste
bis zum ende des krieges
[Musik]
die atlantic schlacht war die zentrale
logistik schlacht des krieges
sieg oder niederlage entschieden über
den weiteren verlauf des gesamten
krieges
ausschlaggebend waren weiter
entwicklungen bei den geheimdiensten die
zunehmenden fähigkeiten der geleitschutz
kräfte und bestimmte technische
entwicklungen wie zb teilsystemen
ticketing system
die industrie in den usa war in der lage
alle erforderlichen ressourcen für diese
schlacht bereit zu stellen die
eigentlich ein wettkampf der
produktionskapazitäten war
[Musik]
immerhin wissen die menschen in
großbritannien was die seeleute
durchmachen wie ein geretteter matrose
feststellt
[Musik]
die fahrt in der londoner u-bahn in salz
befleckter uniform und mit
orangefarbener schwimmweste unter dem
arm war eine größere tour als den
atlantik zu überqueren
überall menschenmassen die sich um mich
drängten um mehr auf den rücken zu
klopfen oder die hand zu schütteln
[Musik]
die atlantic schlacht unterbricht immer
wieder die lieferketten auf der insel
mangelt es an vielem
vor dem krieg liefen jeden tag zehn bis
15 schiffe mit lebensmitteln in
britischen helfen ein diese zahl
halbierte sich mit kriegsbeginn
churchill sei im gewinnen der atlantik
schlacht den schlüssel zum sieg und in
vielerlei hinsicht hatte er recht aber
die versorgungslage in großbritannien
blieb trotzdem erstmal miserabel
[Musik]
1938 importiert großbritannien 68
millionen tonnen güter
1941 sind es nur noch 26 millionen
golfplätze werden umgepflügt und
bepflanzt nahrungsmittel rationiert
ersatzprodukte verteilt der einbruch der
importe führt dazu dass weizenmehl knapp
wird
weissbrodt wird verboten stattdessen ein
dunkles vollkornbrot eingeführt der
sogenannte national los es ist nicht
besonders beliebt
[Musik]
zwiebeln sind begehrt als preise bei
tombolas und beliebte
geburtstagsgeschenke aber während sich
die ernährung im krieg für die
mittelschicht verschlechtert wird sich
für die arbeiterklasse sogar besser
sadie atlantik schlacht war entscheidend
aber sie bedrohten ii das überleben der
briten
[Musik]
anders sieht es im besetzten europa aus
dort hungern millionen
[Musik]
am 30 januar 1942 dem neunten jahrestag
seiner ernennung zum reichskanzler
spricht hitler im berliner sportpalast
dieser krieg wird nicht so ausgehen wie
die juden sich s vorstellen nämlich dass
die europäischen völker ausgerottet
werden sondern das ergebnis dieses
krieges ist die vernichtung des
judentums
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in den ghettos ist hitlers ziel längst
realität
moshe fischmann erlebt das grauen
am ende waren wir zu zehnt in einem
zimmer wir schliefen in schichten
[Musik]
auf der hand liegen der hygienischen
bedingungen brachte france aus
es gab keine medizin dass wir hatten
musste reingeschmuggelt werden
außerhalb des ghettos ohne armbinde
angetroffen wurde wurde getötet
die menschen sterben wie die fliegen
[Musik]
nexway rasch einen kamen die ration
skaten als deutscher bekam man glaube
ich
2180 kalorien pro tag
über als pole bekommst du 604 ehemann
jude war bekam man 300 davon waren
vielleicht 180 s bar den rest konntest
du wegschmeißen
gibt es reichte erst mal gerade so zum
überleben aber über die zeit
verhungerten die menschen einfach eine
body hinter jeden den sie für nicht
lebenswert hielten hunger die deutschen
auf diese weise zu tode
[Musik]
in großbritannien führt die atlantic
schlacht nicht direkt zu hungersnot sie
bedeutet aber mangel und minderwertige
ersatzprodukte in anderen ländern wird
die unterbrechung von versorgungslinien
zu einer frage des überlebens
das vereinigte königreich ist eine insel
nation
japan ist eine nation von inseln
die japaner hatten schon bei
kriegseintritt der usa sehr spärlich
ration es kam noch schlimmer japan war
auf auslands importe angewiesen und auch
auf den schiffsverkehr zwischen den
inseln
die amerikanische u-boot angriffe
sehr effektiv
einen monat nach pearl harbor am 17
januar 1942 versenkte uss pollackvor
tokio einen japanischen frachter
es ist das erste von über 1.000
japanischen handelsschiffen die von
amerikanischen boden versenkt werden
und die japaner wissen einen
zermürbungskrieg können sie nicht
gewinnen
admiral yamamoto oberbefehlshaber der
kaiserlichen japanischen marine sagt zum
premierminister in den ersten sechs bis
zwölf monaten eines krieges mit den
vereinigten staaten und großbritannien
werde ich mich austoben und sieg um sieg
erringen
aber wenn der krieg danach weiter geht
habe ich keine aussicht auf erfolg
[Musik]
tatsächlich bringt japan innerhalb von
nur fünf monaten riesige gebiete unter
seine kontrolle
allerdings gegen schwache widersacher
der krieg gegen hitler hat die ohnehin
unzureichende verteidigung der
alliierten im pazifischen raum
zusätzlich geschwächt
[Musik]
viele ihrer anführer agieren inkompetent
und rassistisch verbot
rassistischer vorurteile führen anfangs
dazu dass die alliierten die stärke des
japanischen militärs unterschätzen eins
habe ich unterschätzt seine
beweglichkeit und seine kampfkraft
restemeyer so konnten die japaner die
gebiete die sie angriffen schnell unter
ihre kontrolle bringen
[Musik]
selbst in der niederlage zeigen die
briten keinen respekt
general archie broadway will nennt die
japanischen truppen
eine armee von hoch trainierten
gangstern
auch bei den japanern ist rassismus
stark ausgeprägt ein handbuch klärt die
soldaten über die menschen in den
besetzten gebieten auf
[Applaus]
wir wollen vielleicht schnell männer aus
ihnen machen aber wir sollten nicht zu
viel erwarten
races um rassismus ist eine der
wichtigsten erklärungen dafür dass die
japaner nie so eng mit den deutschen
zusammen arbeiteten wie es möglich
gewesen wäre
[Musik]
aus der britischen kolonie malaria
kommen damals 38 prozent der weltweiten
kautschuk und fast 60 prozent der
zinkproduktion
ein lohnendes ziel für die japaner
trotzdem lässt sich die britische
streitmacht vor ort überrumpeln kaum hat
der kampf auf der malaiischen halbinsel
begonnen stellt ein japanischer offizier
fest das einzige worauf wir achten
mussten war es keine munition zu
vergeuden und gründlich vorzugehen
der bericht wusste die britischen
streitkräfte verteidigten die straßen
und schienenwege von den straßen und
schienenwegen aus denn die braucht man
um mit seinen truppen schnell
voranzukommen sie errichteten
verteidigungsposition mit artillerie
stellungen ihr ziel dabei die japaner
zum stillstand bringen dann die
artillerie einsetzten und sie vernichten
für die briten waren die straßen immer
das wichtigste und deshalb verteidigten
sie die japaner nutzen das auf kluge
weise aus sie griffen von der flanke aus
an immer wenn die briten dort eine
verteidigungsstellung hatten machten die
japaner einen bogen darum und kamen
durch den dschungel die briten waren
überrumpelt und zogen sich zurück
[Musik]
ein britischer offizier beschreibt die
schnelligkeit des japanischen vormarsch
innerhalb von zwei minuten fuhren ein
dutzend mit laura panzer an mir vorbei
sie donnerten direkt durch unsere
vorderen linien
general yamashita befehlshaber der
japanischen invasion streitkräfte
verfügt über 150 panzer
[Musik]
keine besonders guten aber das spielt
keine rolle
denn die briten haben gar keine
britischen imperium die britischen
streitkräfte waren für den
dschungelkrieg ziemlich schlecht
vorbereitet den die ein großteil der
truppe kam von der indischen armee die
männer waren im wesentlichen für die
ebenen und hügel indiens ausgebildet was
nützt ihnen im dschungelcamp wien
yamashita es männer haben schon in china
gekämpft aber auch für sie ist es der
erste dschungelkrieg
ein japanischer oberst bemerkt ein zog
sich zurück und ließ als souvenir 50
fällt geschütze 50 schwere
maschinengewehre und 300 lastwagen
zurück ein anderer oberst brüstet sich
wir hatten so viele titel vorräte wir
brauchten keinen einzigen sack reis zu
transportieren
virtual vorräte so nennen die japaner
spöttisch die zurückgelassenen
vorratslager der alliierten die mit
japaner hatten befehl churchills
rationen also die vorräte der britischen
soldaten zu plündern das war immer teil
der strategie
der japanische soldat war besser
motiviert besser ausgebildet und besser
vorbereitet als sein britisches oder
australisches gegenüber
[Musik]
auch australische truppen kämpfen auf
seiten der alliierten
ein bataillon sieht mit dem lied
waltzing mathilda in den kampf
die letzte große schlacht des feldzugs
ist die schlacht von mo
[Musik]
general yamashita erklärt
die schlacht von moore war die
grausamste des gesamten feldzugs die
überlebenden der feindlichen truppen
können mit fug und recht stolz sein sie
haben in einer einwöchigen blutigen
schlacht ohne jegliche panzer und
luftunterstützung meine gesamte armee
aufgehalten
[Musik]
als die japanischen truppen singapur
erreichen sind sie den verteidigern
zahlenmäßig zwei zu eins unterlegen
die männer sind 55 tage lang marschiert
und knapp an munition
trotzdem überrollen die japaner den
schlecht organisierten gegner
[Musik]
in den reihen der alliierten truppen
stehen viele neue rekruten ohne kampf
erfahrung
[Musik]
am 13 februar ertönt eine ansprache der
japaner in englischer sprache über die
stadt
singapur heißt es da sei kein zweites
dünkirchen
[Musik]
zwei tage später schreibt lieutenant
general of a possible in sein tagebuch
da ist weder hilfe noch hoffnung am
horizont
keine die moral der britischen truppen
war schlagartig dahin
die japaner die wasserversorgung der
stadt eroberten war alles vorbei zu
diesem zeitpunkt war es ein leichtes die
britischen streitkräfte zu belagern
as possible ergibt sich
[Musik]
mit seinem auftreten seinem outfit
seinen begleitern und wie sie ihre
flagge tragen wirkt er wie eine parodie
eines oberbefehlshabers des britischen
empire
er ist der perfekte sündenbock
[Musik]
das ganze stand symbolisch für den
zustand des empire in asien es war die
ausgehöhlt ohne substanz
eine kundin mit akon ein land das
churchill überhaupt nicht ernst genommen
hatte konnte es einfach so besiegen es
war eine katastrophe
eine demütigung und es ließ sich vor dem
parlament nur schwer erklären
als 18-jähriger sieht league one you
später der erste premierminister des
unabhängigen singapur wie sich die
britischen soldaten in gefangenschaft
begeben
drei tage lang trampelten sie an meinem
haus vorbei ein endloser strom
verwirrter männer
erstaunlich rabiater gewalt besetzen die
japaner das jubelpaar des ostens 123
jahre britische geschichte verloren in
sieben tagen
briten und australier waren den
japanischen truppen in britisch maria
und in singapur zahlenmäßig überlegen
aber die japanischen soldaten kämpften
sie nieder und ihre befehlshaber
entschieden klüger
für singapur und die kriegsgefangenen
beginnt eine harte zeit
es ist so george
die größte katastrophe und kapitulation
in der britischen geschichte
wenn man schon verliert dann wenigstens
mit würde und anstand wie singapur
gefallen war traf churchill ins mark er
sagte wir hatten so viele männer sie
hätten sich besser anstellen müssen er
war zutiefst betrübt die britischen
soldaten waren in britisch maria nicht
nur keine helden gewesen sondern nicht
einmal anständige soldaten sie waren
einfach in sich zusammengefallen
die japanische sichtweise kommt im
tagebuch eines soldaten zum ausdruck
ich begrüße das jahr 1942 ein jahr von
großer bedeutung mein körper und mein
geist sind so klar und rein wie der
blaue himmel in diesem jahr mehr als in
jedem anderen müssen wir den weg des
kriegers gehen
das klingt nach würde und anstand
aber die realität ist eine andere
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in den besetzten gebieten beginnt das
morden der zivilbevölkerung
die japaner bekämpften die chinesen
schon seit einem jahrzehnt und nachdem
sie singapur erobert hatten wendeten sie
sich gegen die chinesische bevölkerung
von singapur so ging das große massaker
an den chinesin war die erste grosse
tragödie die japanischen besatzung
konnte
im februar und märz 1942 werden in
britisch malaria und singapur
zehntausende chinesen während der zum
massaker abgeschlachtet
die japanischen militärs hatten
bestimmte gruppen von menschen definiert
die als unerwünscht galten darunter
ehemalige rekruten der freiwilligen
einheiten kommunisten potenzielle
unruhestifter und auch intellektuelle
und wohlhabende
die japanischen militärs hatten enorme
macht und gegenüber den völkern ost
asiens deren länder sie eroberten hatten
sie eine unglaublich rassistische
geringschätzen der einstellung
zu den schauplätzen der massaker gehören
die strände von
tanguy karton panamera und bela kathi
allein in singapur sollen bei der großen
inspektion wie die japaner das blutbad
verharmlosen landen 6.000 bis 10.000
nach manchen schätzungen bis zu 25.000
menschen getötet worden sein
bei solchen gräueltaten schaan die
anführer normalerweise verschiedene
gruppen von menschen um ein gemeinsames
ideologisches oder politisches programm
nur so ist gewalt in solchem ausmaß
möglich aber es gibt nicht nur das eine
motiv auch nicht nur die eine denkweise
[Musik]
wenige tage nach der eroberung britisch
x alias greifen die japanischen
streitkräfte
niederländisch ostindien und seine
wertvollen ölfelder an
das entscheidende gefecht wird als die
schlacht in der java sie in die
geschichtsbücher eingehen
der niederländische admiral karel
tormann kann nicht verhindern dass die
japanischen flugzeuge und kriegsschiffe
seien alliierte flotte vernichten zehn
schiffe und 2000 mann darunter auch
dormann selbst versinken im meer
japan verliert lediglich einen
truppentransporter
nach der landung dauern die kämpfe noch
eine woche
[Applaus]
[Musik]
schon zwei monate zuvor so wenige
stunden nach pearl harbor hatten die
japaner die britische kolonie hongkong
angegriffen
[Musik]
nach einwöchigem bonbon überbringen
japanische gesandte im hafen von
hongkong eine botschaft für den
britischen gouverneur
sir mark young schickt sie mit seiner
antwort zurück
der gouverneur und oberbefehlshaber von
hongkong lehnt es strikt ab über die
kapitulation von hongkong zu verhandeln
das ist mutig aber folgenschwer
am nächsten tag landen japanische
truppen begleitet von schwerem
artilleriefeuer auf der insel hongkong
der japanische kommandeur der ersten
welle oberst tanaka befiehlt seinem
regiment keine gefangenen zu machen
die soldaten gehorchen
eine knappe woche später kapituliert
hongkong
doch die gräueltaten sind damit noch
nicht zu ende
[Musik]
seit 1902 sind die philippinen de facto
eine kolonie der usa
eigentlich sollte das land bis 1945
unabhängig werden aber der krieg
durchkreuzt die pläne
general douglas macarthur soll als
militärberater die philippinische armee
organisieren er nennt sie eine offensiv
wie defensiv ungeheuer starke kraft
mcaffee hat rund
150.000 soldaten etwa 130.000 davon sind
viele kinos aber es fehlen zentrale
waffen und kampfflugzeuge und es gibt
ein sprachproblem dazu ist die
ausbildung der rekruten schlecht
viele kinos wussten natürlich dass da
etwas auf sie zukam der letzte krieg war
aber eine weile her sie waren nicht auf
kampf eingestellt als es schließlich los
gehen
[Musik]
siebeneinhalb stunden nach pearl harbor
bombardieren die japaner looser die
größte insel der philippinen
[Musik]
viele der amerikanischen flugzeuge
werden am boden zerstört
kurz danach gehen die ersten japanischen
invasionstruppen an land
[Musik]
[Applaus]
macarthur berichtet
meine tapferen divisionen halten die
stellung und verwehren dem feind den
heiligen boden der philippinen
aber das stimmt nicht
nach der haupt landung rücken die
japaner schnell nach manila vor um die
hauptstadt vor zerstörung zu schützen
wird sie zur offenen stadt erklärt am
zweiten januar 1942 besetzt die
japanische armee manila es kommt zu
massen erschießungen folter und
vergewaltigungen die alliierten haben
sich zuvor auf die halbinsel bataan
zurückgezogen am 22 januar ordner
general macarthur den rückzug auf die
letzte verteidigungslinie an
am 24 januar telegrafierte nach
washington ich beabsichtige bis zur
völligen vernichtung zu kämpfen doch
rose world zieht metapher von den
philippinen ab unter nennt ihn zum
oberbefehlshaber der alliierten truppen
im südwestpazifik
am 11 märz wird er per u-boot nach
australien gebracht
[Musik]
nachdem die alliierten die japaner ein
monat aufgehalten hatten beginnt anfang
april die letzte japanische offensive
auf button die alliierten streitkräfte
kapitulieren nach einer woche general
king der das kommando übernommen hatte
fr gegenüber
werden unsere truppen gut behandelt
werden die antwort wir sind keine
barbaren
aber die siegreichen japaner verhalten
sich barbarisch
rund 70.000 kriegsgefangene müssen unter
sengender sonne mit kaum nahrung und
wasser 100 kilometer weit marschieren
es ist der todesmarsch von bataan
[Musik]
die zahl der todesopfer wird auf bis zu
18.000 geschätzt
die überlebenden werden zu zwangsarbeit
herangezogen
nach kriegsende kehrte nur 15.000 die
ice in die usa zurück
[Musik]
kriegsgefangene gelten den japanern als
menschen ohne ehre da sie nicht bis in
den tod gekämpft haben
in ihren gefangenenlagern sterben viele
alliierte soldaten an erschöpfung wasser
und nahrungsmangel
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in den usa werden japaner und amerikaner
japanischer herkunft
ausgegrenzt und diskriminiert
[Applaus]
präsident roosevelt executive order 9000
66 soll angeblich spionage verhindern
sie erlaubt alle personen an der
westküste von denen eine mögliche
bedrohung ausgeht im landesinneren zu
internieren
dabei werden zwar keine ethnischen
gruppen genannt aber es werden
ausgangssperren erlassen die nur für
japanisch stämmigen amerikaner gelten
im märz 1942 erlässt lieutenant general
john r youtube auf der grundlage der
anordnung die öffentliche proklamation
nummer vier
mit ihr beginnt an der westküste die
zwangsevakuierung und die internierung
von allen menschen japanischer
abstammung
den betroffenen wird eine frist von 48
stunden eingeräumt um zu organisieren
was mit ihren häusern ihren geschäften
und ihrem besitz geschehen soll
zwischen märz und august werden 112.000
menschen davon fast 70.000 amerikanische
staatsbürger in lagern eingesperrt
[Musik]
und das ohne anklage oder die
möglichkeit sich gegen den
freiheitsentzug und den verlust von
eigentum zu wehren
[Musik]
die lager selbst gleichen armee baracken
liegen abseits größere ortschaften und
werden vom us militär bewacht
[Applaus]
mitnehmen können die familie nur das was
sie am leibe tragen und was in ein paar
koffer und taschen passt
sie müssen bis zum ende des krieges in
den lagern ausharren
drei jahre lang
am 5 bei nur zehn wochen nach der
unterzeichnung von rose wels anordnung
9000 66 schießen die japaner die
philippinische insel korridor sturmreif
dann landen sie am
sechsten mal schick general wainwright
eine nachricht
mit tiefem bedauern und anhaltendem
stolz auf meine tapferen truppen treffe
ich mich mit dem japanischen kommandeur
auf wiedersehen mister präsident
am abend bietet er dem japanischen
general homer die kapitulation an der
besteht darauf dass alle verbliebenen
alliierten kräfte auf den philippinen
die waffen strecken
[Musik]
wainwright akzeptiert
[Applaus]
in europa bereiten die deutschen eine
sommeroffensive im kaukasus vor mit dem
ziel sich die ölfelder der sowjets
einzuverleiben
japan ist über südostasien und den
pazifik nur so hinweggefegt
noch sind die achsenmächte auf dem
vormarsch
aber nur wenige wochen nach der
kapitulation der alliierten auf den
philippinen treffen die us pazifikflotte
und die kaiserliche japanische flotte
bei midway aufeinander
bis zum ende des jahres 1942 werden auf
den schlachtfeldern in nordafrika der
sowjetunion und im pazifikraum zahllose
menschen ihr leben lassen